Ein Jäger auf der Flucht
vor seinem Hochsitz.
Ein Landwirt entdeckt eine Wasserader.
Und ein Autorennen auf dem Feld.
Die ostdeutschen Trabis
– inzwischen Kult –
jagen einen modernen SUV.
Das alles sind Inszenierungen
für vorbeifahrende Züge
– und Teil der Kunstaktion
„Bewegtes Land“.
Auf einer 30 Kilometer
langen Zugstrecke
zwischen Naumburg in Sachsen-Anhalt
und Jena in Thüringen
machen die Anwohner
Theater für die Reisenden.
Dass man nicht immer nur aufs
Handy oder den Bildschirm schaut,
sondern wirklich dann mal bewusst
in die Landschaft blickt.
Die Kulisse ist zauberhaft, und
natürlich die einzelne[n] Beiträge,
die dann da in die Landschaft
gestellt werden, sind schon speziell.
Das macht gute Laune!
Ein paar Kilometer weiter basteln
Anwohner noch an den Requisiten.
Als Busch getarnt gehen sie in Stellung.
Das Feld ist ihre Bühne.
Der Auftritt wird nur wenige
Sekunden dauern.
Diese Verwunderung und
diese Überraschung, dieser Moment,
den wollen wir den
Zuschauern bieten und …,
damit sie sich auch freuen, dass
die Büsche auf einmal losrennen.
Die Verwirrung der Zuschauer ist
ein Grundkonzept der Aufführungen
Was ist echt? Was ist inszeniert?
Mal scheint ein Baum zu brennen.
Mal bevölkern Steinzeitmenschen
die Gegend.
Oder: Ein Hai greift an.
Ausgedacht haben sich das
Jörn Hintzer und Jakob Hüfner,
Medienkünstler und Professoren
für Experimentelle Television.
Vor, was weiß ich, vor 15 Jahren hätte
man sich nicht vorstellen können,
dass man sozusagen durchs Internet so
Bildersuche macht und 15.000 Bilder
durchschnittlich am Tag so …
so als Thumbnails anguckt, ja?
Das macht ja total was
mit … mit einem selbst.
Und das ist für uns eigentlich
so dieses Zugfahren, ja,
obwohl ’s ja eigentlich schon fast ’n altes
Transportmittel ist, heutzutage, ja?
[Das] ist für uns so ’n bisschen die
Analogie dazu, zu diesen neuen Medien.
Man fährt also an … ganz schnell an Sachen
vorbei, guckt sie sich nicht richtig an,
aber es sind lauter so Thumbnails,
an denen man vorbeifährt.
Hunderte Freiwillige machen mit.
In dem kleinen Dorf Döbritschen sind fast
alle Einwohner auf den Beinen
– und ihren Leitern. Die Idee:
Sie sind auf Augenhöhe mit den Reisenden
und schauen zurück in den Zug.
Es ist natürlich schön, wenn was los ist,
wenn unsere Einwohner auch
mitmachen können, partizipieren
– also erst mal ein
schönes Wochenende.
Und dass man einfach guckt,
dass man sieht,
das ist ein sehr besonderer Landstrich.
Er ist jetzt nicht wirklich groß bekannt,
also noch ein bisschen [ein] Geheimtipp.
Aber vielleicht zieht’s den einen
oder anderen dann doch hierher!
Die Züge passieren neun Bahnhöfe.
Und überall ist ordentlich was los.
In Naumburg singt ein Chor in
die offenen Waggontüren.
Hier startet auch Rocco einen
Wettlauf gegen den Zug.
Der Trick: 25 identisch gekleidete
Läufer erwecken den Eindruck,
der Mensch sei schneller als die Maschine.
Für die Macher eine Auseinandersetzung mit
dem Thema Mobilität und Geschwindigkeit.
Für die Läufer vor allem ein großer Spaß
und ein kleines Stück Völkerverständigung.
Es ist einfach lustig, so etwas in
einer Gruppe zu machen.
Und ich wollte mehr über die
lokale Kultur erfahren.
Für mich als Ausländerin war
es wirklich interessant.
Gegen den rasenden Rocco
hat der Zug natürlich nie eine Chance.
Die Akteure bespielen insgesamt
24 Züge an zwei Aufführungstagen.
Für die rennenden Büsche heißt das
zweimal pro Stunde übers Feld flitzen.
Wir ... wir kannten uns vorher alle nicht.
Ja, und ich finde das unheimlich spannend.
Also, das ist … Leute … nette
Leute kennenlernen, Spaß haben.
Und ich denke mal, das ist auch so die
Sache von dieser … von dieser Aktion,
dass man halt mit anderen Leuten
gemeinsam was tut.
Inszenierungen für vorbeifahrende
Züge: Eine Kunstaktion,
die die Bewohner in
Bewegung versetzt
– und die Zugreisenden in Verzückung.